[Music]
okay everybody this is my review
of season four episode two of the
handmaid's tale
nightshade this was written by keira
schneider
who has written a couple episodes each
season since
season one so she is no newbie to this
and this is directed by colin watkinson
who directed the first episode and is
the main cinematographer on the show as
i always do i'm going to split up my
review we're going to talk about june's
plot line first then we'll go to canada
and we'll finish off with the waterfords
so with june's plotline
it's still really tense right it opens
up with these guardians looking for the
guardian they
just killed in episode one so june knows
again what she always believed they're
not gonna be able to rest right they
already gotta get
out of there they gotta get on the move
so she's gotta go to this other may day
contact so when she meets this contact
in this greenhouse it's at this new
location that's like
this country club version of jezebel's
and there's women being used as
prostitutes there's these greedy men
from gilead all around
and what's interesting about the
dialogue with this contact from mayday
she meets in the greenhouse
is that she also knows about june so
this word is just spreading more and
more about the legacy of june
and she's even mentioning how it's
inspired people to even blow up
checkpoints per se so that's really cool
i like they're doing that and
it really just works well to kind of
build up the world building and the lore
of june as a character in the handmaid's
tale world because we know
they're gonna make a show based off the
newer book the testaments which i read
which was really good
but you'll see they're just kind of
planning out certain things that will
matter way later because again they're
planning to do so many seasons of the
show and spin-offs but you see
that this contact says they can't get
them out tonight it would have to be
tomorrow so this is huge because we know
how this episode
ends and how the timing of this can make
things more of a struggle for june but
what that sets up for this episode is
that
jun's like well in the meantime i'm
going to help these women here in this
country club and what she shows this may
day contact is that
you know mayday isn't an army it's not
just going to come and liberate a city
right you have to get rid of that
expectations june's learn that
and that you got to do things for
yourself and they plant that seed here
in the greenhouse no pun intended and it
gets its payoff
later on and what i've been really
digging about this season we're getting
a lot of
seeds planted in episodes and paid off
by the end of the episode which i really
appreciate to keep you
patient for the bigger payoffs that go
on the whole season arc and we're going
to see that again right where
we get this reveal which i talked about
episode one where mrs keys you're
wondering what's going on mr keys that
he's out of it we learned mrs keys
has been poisoning him slowly but what
i'm talking about with a seed planted
here is when jun's talking to mrs keys
there's some really good dialogue
and she's talking about i think there
are good men everywhere even in gilead
it's just really hard to be good in
gilead and she's telling this to mrs
keys
who is saying she doesn't believe in
good men anymore because of this
commander who's not a good person
why i love this line by june is it's
kind of just setting you up in your mind
to kind of question what june and miss
keys are talking about and
is there any good men in gilead and it's
giving you that payoff because of this
guardian that is with june this whole
episode
that by the end you know he stands to
stay with
her and not leave her and he gets killed
for it and it also
i believe is kind of setting up to this
character of nick that we've known from
the beginning
how good is nick at the end of the day
and the mystery about nick and where he
is now but before it gets that crazy
end with june let's go now june brings
this poison
to the country club and like i said
we're getting our payoff now where she's
telling this contact look
you gotta take initiative here and do
things for yourself gives her the poison
to put in the vodka and in the tea for
that
and and it's a cool way to show them
kind of take care of gilead in a fresh
way where
we're seeing these guys partying and
they're taking shots of poison not even
realizing it's it's a pretty
awesome sequence to be honest i enjoyed
it but you get this big victory
and it's turned around by this amazing
sequence that ends the episode with june
and this guardian
showing up to the farm and something
feels off right away your heart is just
pounding what they brilliantly do is
they pump in heart-pounding sound in the
background to even hamp it up more
and like i said this guardian doesn't
leave her side he says i'm staying with
you
again just reminding the audience too
that there are some
good men here it gives some hope in that
angle of it and when he gets
shot by a sniper that scared the crap
out of me they timed it perfectly here
to get you on the edge and then just
shocked by it
and it's just crazy tension where these
snipers are on june
and nick appears and we get this crazy
reunion
of nick and june because it's such a
complicated relationship they have had
going this whole show it's one of the
strengths of the show it's happy to see
them back together but it's in such an
odd circumstance because
june is captured here but he does say to
her i'll try to keep you alive but i'm
not gonna speculate here
episode three is already out so let's
just watch episode three and then talk
about an episode three review about
what's going on here at nick
but again awesome cliffhanger for the
episode it's one of the most exciting
scenes i can remember
in recent time for handmaid's foreign
really really enjoyed it and you're
worried already
like what's going on with alma and
janine and mrs keys so it
it adds that mystery to it which is
exciting so let's now shift gears to
the canada storyline that is with our
protagonists
in luke moira rita and emily now i've
been hard on the canada story line in
past seasons
and i've always said it's the slowest
part of the show it is still the slowest
part of the show
but on second watch this episode i
actually really dug
this story in particular with
moira but before it even delves too much
into moira i like also seeing rita now
because
rita being in canada is interesting
because she's had the most longing
effects of gilead she's been equili at
the longest and now she's
really more of a fish out of water here
and they tie that well because
everyone on this plane is like all of
these kids and it goes into something
that's
very realistic of how this would happen
if this really happened in real life
where you can't just have kids raised in
the world they know
now just blend into a different society
it's not going to be a smooth transition
and they also do a great job of leaning
into survivors guilt now
and really making our characters face
that and rita still got
that gilead in her because she's like i
thank god i'm here every day i pray for
june every day she's still talking
a little bit that way a very in a
religious state that's what i love about
moira she's like
i'd pray for gilead which was a great
transition into june's
scenes but before we get even into the
moira and
emily plotline here the big criticism i
do have about this episode it's
very few criticism but this one stuck
out to me was that i did not
like how they paced this episode and
edited it where
you had june's really interesting main
plot but when you would go
to canada and then it would go to the
other side of canada with the waterfords
they would plot it out you see this at
18 minutes in the episode
and you'll see it at 29 minutes episode
where it's right in the middle of patch
to really slow the pace which i didn't
like was that
they would play those story lines back
to back and then go to june where
i think it would just been smoother for
the whole episode they were going june
then moira then june or vice versa but
not
putting the b and c plot next to each
other it's
too much slowness to really take away
from the excitement of the main plot and
that's
a struggle all movies and shows have
where anytime you're leaving your main
protagonist which is june
the main storyline you gotta make sure
it's really interesting and these other
plots so people don't get antsy to get
back to where they really want to be
and keep those things interesting which
i think they were interesting on their
own but to have
those side plots play back to back was
just too long and it made them feel
slower but
back to what we're talking about now in
this storyline right we see
moira has this new chick she's into
and of course there's a reason emily's
there in that scene seeing that
it's planning just speculation it's a
fan thing that people want
where emily and moira would get together
that's the characters we know and love
right so of course you're rooting for
that
so i thought it was interesting she was
the one to see that because that could
definitely be a possibility down the
road but what i really did like was
moira here with this child of asher
who's getting
adopted right and it hits a lot of
things what it really did well with
moyra's character
is it really delved into her struggle of
taking on instant parenthood which she's
actually relating to this woman who's
adopting asher but what it's also doing
is showing you an example of how a kid's
not gonna adapt well to this
life that we know is normal but to them
it's foreign like this
kid doesn't even like pizza which is
insane right
he misses his martha he misses his room
he misses his mom and dad
he misses the food from gilead but you
see how
the mother adopting him is just
frustrated and moira's already learning
she's like
you gotta just let him feel these things
you can't keep correcting him and we get
this little thing which is
pretty crazy where she named the kid
she's trying to call him james named
after her brother who is the actual
father of this kid so
obviously we can assume he's clearly
dead and that she's taking on
her nephew here and we get this good
scene with emily and moira now where
they're talking about
like hey june didn't think this through
or these kids ripped from their families
the only lives they knew wouldn't adapt
well and this would be
chaos and we get more into morrow saying
i love nicole
but i never wanted to be a mom and emily
says why do you feel like you have to
clean up june's mess
she says this great line i'm making up
for when i got out and she didn't i
guess
but i'm tired of feeling guilty so this
is really good it gets us into a
character we love
that really hasn't got enough screen
time and we haven't really got enough
into her head in moira
and why she's a great character is she's
from the beginning with june and she had
a completely different experience in
june now getting out so early
but it goes into that survivor guilt
that i think is really interesting and
how you adapt your life to it and
where's the line of doing all these
things out of guilt where you also need
to take care of yourself
it really just feels realistic and how
this would go down in real life
and come on i mean samira wiley is an
incredible actress every time i watch a
show i'm like man how is she not even
a bigger star in getting bigger roles i
think she deserves to be
a huge star because she can make one
scene 10 times better just with her
skills and
just what she gives off but moira has
this genius idea to bring rita over and
it shows a genius idea by the writers
here and how to use rita as a character
and interesting
in this candidate story that's usually
been kind of slow but you're like okay
she's that taste of gilead these kids
are gonna need now to transition it's a
perfect role for rita as she's trying to
transition herself
and there's some subtle humor here i
love where
she gives the kid this wooden elephant
to play with and the kid's all excited
and moira's like
what like she's used to kids being
excited playing with like video games
and the kids excited for
rita to make food that was like in
gilead it's just
kind of funny in a way which i like
there's like a little humor in a very
serious
show so now let's shift over to the
waterfords okay so
a lot of stuff's going on here in plot
progression for the waterford some big
stuff so we see serena's having a full
physical evaluation
and they're basically giving her an out
here like mark is always trying to give
serena a door
to her getting redemption and she's not
taking it
and that's serena we know that's the
serena we know
we we are we love we've been with this
character in the top where you love her
then you hate her then you love her
hater and she just won't make that full
redemption arc happen she's very
complicated and
continues to be the most interesting
character to me on the show but you see
she's got her missing finger
from fred she's gotten her different
forms of abuse
that obviously is having sex with a
woman that she could have stds
and they talk about when he struck her
and they're like oh is this another
appropriate punishment and she's like
it's not that simple
you get that famous shot handmade loves
where it's like that out of focus
close up showing the anxiety serena
feels even that mentioned but we see
mark's like look you can get immunity
here get you nicole back
coming out as a victim here towards fred
do the right thing
it's a path for her he's constantly
giving her second chances but she's like
it wasn't abuse not exactly
he acted out of anger and he probably
regrets it and he's like why do you keep
giving him the benefit of the doubt and
i like they threw this line where she's
like because i knew him before gilead so
it gets us more into serena's
justification what is the thing she's
constantly giving fred
passes in her head of how he treats her
if she's holding on to the old fred that
she married and fell in love with
and that was with her during the time of
her starting gilead and she's
created this monster and brought the
worse out in fred
and there's some spell binding
cinematography here which is expected
with this show but i love that
when serena was talking to mark in the
scene you see somehow they got
the rain only on one side for a bit with
serena and there's this light
pounding on mark and stick you just see
she could just go over there with mark
find that light that he's giving her
constantly to go to but she stays in the
dark
world she kind of has created so then we
get this scene where serena wants to see
fred they're in the small chapel and i
love how they
set the setting in the small chapel and
fred's talking about
how he doesn't like that about this
place that they make god
small like that like the small chapel
like they remember in airports and not
how gilead makes that the big thing
and he's like serena you're willing to
expose details of our life and our faith
to strangers and he's like you used to
be so good at getting me to do what you
want but my eyes are open now and she's
like fred please i just want my daughter
back and he's like look
she's just as much as my daughter too
and i'm not gonna just get her and walk
free
fred says this line you made us this way
but she says you never stood up for me
once
once you got a taste of power i thought
it was my fault that i deserved
everything you did to me
they're both right here like they're
both saying truth to each other like
pointing out each other's flaws that
yeah serena is the mastermind behind
this and really did bring out the worst
in both of them
but fred was the one who decided to take
the next level and
forget about serena really and got power
hungry and started treating her awful so
they both are saying things that are
correct but he says i think i gave you
too much freedom so this is where
serena's realizing he is really long
gone
she has to let go of that fred prior to
gilead and you see
she runs to mark's like i need to
separate my interest from fred i'm done
with him
but this doesn't matter at the moment
because we get this big reveal from mark
that she's pregnant now i'm going to
give a shout out to the handmaid's tale
fans and reddit
and the community because i love about
shows now where people can
really catch symbolism and hints towards
things and
when season 3 episode 11 came out
remember on their way to the border
serena and fred they had this really
kind of romantic moment where they're at
this house on the way there they're
reconnecting
and they're laying in those separate
beds near each other but someone pointed
out on reddit this picture here where
you see
it's all imagery of the womb here
with the lamp between the two beds so
that was your hint that serena was
pregnant so nice catch by that person
they called it but it's a huge
cliffhanger as well in its own way for
this episode so i really like this
episode left two exciting cliffhangers
with this big reveal
and i think that we got some really good
character study of
moira but also interesting how they're
handling the kids with
rita my only complaint in this episode
like i said is the decision to have
both canada's stories back to back twice
in this episode they should have spread
it out more in between the main plot
with june
maybe even save some of the scenes for
the next episode
but i dug it i really enjoyed it more my
second viewing the first time it did
feel really slow but
i really really liked it again on
rewatch
i suggest re-watching this one again i
think i like it more i'm gonna give this
one an 8.8 i'm excited for the next
episode knowing it is written by bruce
miller
and directed by elizabeth moss
june herself so i'm excited to see what
she's got in that territory that review
is out
now you can check it out after watch
episode three and i'll talk all about it
so please make sure to subscribe don't
miss one of my reviews of handmaid's
tale
i'll be reviewing every episode so you
don't want to miss that please follow me
at steve arley's show on twitter
instagram for more of me and if you
really like what i do here i appreciate
a commitment to a two dollar monthly
donation so i can do more videos for you
guys cover
more shows it will really help me to
live the dream of doing this full time
one day for you
and like i said it helps me so much if
you just subscribe to the channel you
have no idea how many doors it opens up
for me so
i really appreciate it and i'll see you
next time